self-talk without real work is just a
lie yeah
so my self-talk is the reminiscing back
on the struggle to get to this moment
your mind has a tactical advantage over
you at all times it knows your
weaknesses it knows your strengths and
it will guide you into your nice comfort
zone ya wanna be happy
build a life not just a business hey
it's Evan Carmichael and this channel
was created to help you overcome the
number one challenge that is holding you
back a lack of belief in yourself you
watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside you too
you've got Michael Jordan level talent
at something so today let's live your
best believed life and learn how you can
persevere in anything also if you want
to have more confidence in self-love
check out my 250 part series they're
free the link to join on the description
below you will never learn from people
if we always tap-dance around the truth
everything I didn't want to do is what
got me to where I'm at today it's about
what you're saying to yourself but it
also comes at work so whenever I was
getting beat down physically mentally
spiritually whatever I was going through
just saying you know I would put you
know you can't hurt me okay let's kick
it off with rule number one reprogram
your mind with David Goggins your mind
has a tactical advantage over you at all
times it knows your weaknesses it knows
your strengths and it will guide you
into your nice comfort zone yeah we had
to reprogram our mind to get it did it
like a different vantage point so then
you know how to be in charge of yourself
yeah versus your mind being in charge of
you let's say for giggles I'm training
for a hundred mile race yeah let's take
a tour just for giggles I'm training for
a hundred mile race okay good so let's
say I'm training for hundred mile race
and I get to mile fifty yeah and I feel
like mm-hmm
and like everybody else my mind gets
soft mm-hmm why because I'm human yeah
I'm not some damn you know hybrid
creature that was formed from the
heavens above
no not human I suffer I don't like it
I'm uncomfortable I don't like it yeah
so my mind starts to get weak and we
start to forget about how badass where
you are I call that the cookie jar but
it's not about the cookie jar right now
yeah this is about self-talk yeah
but but the cookie jar kind of doors to
self toss - yes a piece of it so
basically what I do here is you have to
make sure that your mind doesn't become
[ __ ] when it's suffering when it's in
pain all it wants to do is find the easy
way out which is usually quit mmm if you
quit the pain goes away immediately yeah
you gotta give yourself enough energy
and fuel in your mind and stay just a
little bit longer so you can talk
yourself into staying for the whole
thing yeah this how it works most of us
never start anything cold if you're
gonna go to college
you gotta study your ass off if you want
to run a hundred mile race a marathon if
you want to go be mr. Olympia if you
want to go be a scientist a doc you one
of the best salespeople and if you're
not worried
you got to work but this you're gonna
build you gotta build up but what
happens is in that moment where we need
self-talk
when we're failing and we're not worth
spot possible yeah we forget that all
the build-up to where we're at today we
forget how much work we put in we forget
that we put years yeah
years maybe not into making these dials
but to getting where you're at today to
become this person become this person to
be in a position to make this money or
if you want to make what everyone's
doing your life yeah we forget that we
forget that journey on what it took for
us to get in this moment to make the
right decision yeah so that's my
self-talk is this okay I won't get too
out of here man I'm done then I remember
this you ran 2,000 miles training to be
in this moment right now we forget that
yeah we forget that 3 o'clock in the
morning runs or getting up early for
work or whatever you're doing we forget
all that in that moment of suffering I
remind myself yeah oh you have 50 more
miles I put in six months of training
you did 60 7030 right exactly this is no
big deal
we forget all of that yeah so what I do
myself talk is basically going back down
memory lane yeah of all those up days I
ran the rain or I had a study rule late
at night and I
to do it but I did it to get here yeah
that's the hook that is the hooks the
hook I wanted to get here now you're
here and now you want to quit yeah so
you got your mind somebody this thing
about it if you haven't put in any hard
work to reflect on your yeah so there is
no suckers you got nothing to pull back
it's just a lie nothing to say hey
you've done this before it's right or
you've done something like this right
all this all this like people want to be
all positive all this positive talk it
doesn't work if it's a lot like if you
didn't study for your big exam and you
go into it saying I'm gonna pass it yeah
no you're not yeah feel it yeah that
self talk is not gonna work self talk
without real work it's just a lie yeah
so my self talk is me reminiscing back
on the struggle to get to this moment
and that tells me we're not quitting
today yeah not today you had a goal to
become like the all-time pull-up
champion of the world right unis Book of
World Records right what did you do to
visualize to get over the hurdle into to
make that real for you so basically you
have to put yourself in the moment a
million times while I'm sitting here
first of all it takes total quietness we
live in the world that's so busy and so
active and moving so fast right now I am
sitting with tom ferry yep
my mind is sitting with tom ferry yeah
it's not talking to tom ferry about
thinking about my god I got order some
more books I'm sorted out of here I'm
doing this and doing that yeah that's
the first thing about visualization yeah
you must be sure to silence out all the
[ __ ] of life which is very hard to
do and it is very hard because the your
your visual picture must be clearish it
has to be clear it can't be like kind of
in and out like a like a fuzzy TV you
got to see it has to become real you can
take a snapshot of it a million times
put in the bank that snapshot of me was
getting that 4021 pull up yeah
knocked out because the wreck was 4020
yeah I visualized that over and over and
over again I visualized
gonna say cuz the guy's name was Stephen
Highland let's take it like what you're
gonna say to me here now on video Riley
got his ass yep so I visualized the
success huh but then I went through
that's the that's the fun part
yeah I have to do 4020 pull-ups to get
to that 4021 pull-up I know now because
it should be three chances yeah to get
it all those failures they were great
for me to examine where I was not bad
along the way so I take all that yeah
and I put in the bank as far as
visualization okay and I get 225 points
to post my hands start to rip okay get
ready for that
so I started visualizing how I got here
on the pain mm-hmm okay then you start
visualizing okay my my nutrition was off
you start visualizing all these things
because you have to mimic it a million
times but I can't mimic 4020 pull-ups by
doing it but you can see all the council
scenes on fails right and see yourself
going beyond it that's right so that
that was my big thing about I had to
walk in get the chalk see I just see
everything over and over and over again
and when I realize I ought to keep that
visual that picture in my head for 17
hours it took me 17 hours to break that
record
so for 17 hours while I used to be loud
everywhere I went I put these headphones
in yeah I never listen to music but
listen to one song going the distance
you know for 17 hours it's 2 minutes and
13 seconds yeah for 17 hours I had that
in that's a lot of rocky a lot of rocky
and I went here yeah for and so I was
able to visualize every rep yeah so I
visualize my hand placement making sure
that felt right before I got going I
didn't ignore olive oil pains my hands
got sweaty okay that means I was aware
of everything means my okay my hands
about to rip it's getting sweaty
wipe it off be aware everything I was
totally in the moment because of how I
visualized everything now of a special
bonus gift from David on how to run into
your fears that I think you're going to
enjoy but
or that it's time for the three-point
landing questions let's go from just
watching a video to taking action here
we go question number one where do you
need to reprogram your mind number two
what obstacles will prevent you from
doing it and number three how will you
overcome those obstacles when they come
up and if you made it this far in a
video and you are committed to making
the change I want to celebrate you give
me a hashtag believe down the comments
as well the most important conversation
you'll ever have is the one you have
with yourself you wake up with it you
walk around with it eventually you act
on it and my self-talk was most
disgusting self-talk of all time so the
sewer of my mind like I said you have to
go back in there and fix things a lot of
us are afraid like right now 20 years
ago
you wouldn't find me on this show I was
too embarrassed to tell you I stuttered
I lied all these different things
getting beat up getting bullied
whatever happened but that's where the
true transformation starts to happen
when you can look at people anybody
thousands of people one person and say
hey this is who I am and this is where I
have to fix myself and this is where it
really happened I thought it happened
when I was in you know 19 18 years old
trying to pass this military test it
happened here when I was almost 300
pounds spraying for cockroaches making
$1,000 a month and you know people
called me dumb people my dad called me
so many things and I am funny being beat
just stripped me of all self-esteem this
is when I realized I was alone on this
earth yeah I have God alone on earth and
I have to fix everything so this is
where I started to develop an
indestructible mental toolbox okay so I
came home one night after spraying for
cockroaches at ecolab and literally I
was praying that Steak and Shake and I
would go across the street to 7-eleven I
had a 45-minute commute home so I worked
an 11 o'clock at night to seven o'clock
in the morning okay
I had a 45-minute commute home and my my
stop would be you know Steak N Shake
chocolate milkshake across the street
7-eleven box of mini chocolate doughnuts
and I would eat that all the way home
yeah sure when I come home I turn the TV
on I take my shake because the box are
doing us we're I mean they were killed
oh yeah I kill those yeah go back to the
back turn this turn the TV on and take a
shower
listen to the TV I'm taking a shower
this day I heard these guys on the tee
you talking about Navy SEAL toughest
class to 24 so I heard stuff about Navy
SEALs you know these are the baddest of
the baddest yeah yeah so I come out now
watching this show I'm drinking my shake
and when you're watching the show of
guys who are putting out there and their
quit quit and left and right
oh just can't help they're going through
hell week they show them go with you
first face second face to face and
they're dropping like flies I looked in
this one guy's eyes who was ringing the
bell to quit to put his helmet down out
of Navy SEAL training and I saw myself
and I saw what everybody said I was
gonna be which was nothing but I said I
was gonna be that that that conversation
you have that's who I was so that's why
I lied to people to tell them a
different version of the truth sure I
had to make all those lies reality I had
to make him real I had I had to become a
real person
so that's one I put in my mind that I'm
gonna go to the toughest military
training on the planet and where it has
the most water the thing I was scared of
the most I had to go back so a lot of us
run away from our fears her and we boxed
ourself in to a lifestyle of this is all
we can do I'm afraid of everything
outside this box yeah so I'm comfortable
inside this box I jumped the box oh you
did it for the first time I laugh
mentally I jumped the box and say hey
come here play if you want more David
Goggins check out the video right there
next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there you're gonna find peace from going
to war with yourself we never life will
start getting good for me God would
throw a nice anchor and stop me right
there